the cars the cars are going gay okay so
Ford Motors put out this ad this is uh
to up you know we've got the gay month
coming June it's the whole month of
gayness uh they're getting ahead of the
game and they put this out for pride
month already here you go
[Music]
it's always better
thank you
yeah
[Music]
all right so first off Connor has a
truck like this and uh Connor I wasn't
going to tell you but as a little this
is a little pre-birthday gift for you
we've out your car right now is outside
in the in the parking lot being uh
detailed rainbow in that whole freaking
thing and you're gonna drive it around
town very proud you straight white freak
um that's one thing uh the other thing
think about it this way let's say gay
people are 10 of the population why what
is the obsession with marketing
everything towards gay trans whatever
and a gay and trans have nothing to do
with each other they're actually Arch
enemies sort of like Optimus Prime and
Megatron gays and trans should not like
each other because the trans want to
chop off the genitals of the gays let's
put that aside for a second uh why would
you be marketing to a very Niche
audience and who what gay person is
walking in when you want to buy a car
and you know okay so you're sitting
there you're looking at two trucks well
which one of these trucks is gayer is
this what is this truck do you do you
have this in Rainbow it's just none of
it makes any sense
foreign
[Music]